there's something that might seem
confusing about Iran the country has an
unelected supreme leader at the top but
it's also got a president who's
democratically elected in votes that are
far from perfect but sure look pretty
important so is Iran a dictatorship or
is it a democracy as it turns out it's
both and seeing that goes a long way to
explaining why the country is the way it
is Iran as we know it today began with a
revolution in 1979 which culminated in a
simple referendum that March Islamic
Republic yes or no but what is an
Islamic Republic
how can a country's government be both
theocratic and representative iran's
revolutionary leaders didn't really know
the answer either and they never agreed
so they ended up creating a government
that has these two systems mashed
together some parts are elected some are
unelected and they're all tangled
together in this kind of mess there's a
real tension between those two systems
Ron Ian's elect more or less
democratically president Parliament
which is called the Mosley's and a
really important body called the
Assembly of Experts
we'll get to that later at the same time
there's the unelected theocracy the
supreme leader the judiciary the
military and others still the supreme
leader really does dominate a rock he
sets the tone for the country's politics
and policies including its nuclear
program and its official hostility to
the West but what happens when the
Supreme Leader dies or gets sick this
turns out to be a really important
question the supreme leader is picked by
a group of about 90 senior Iranian
political and clerical leaders called
the Assembly of Experts but here's where
Iran's Islamic Republic system gets
important the Assembly's members are
elected in a national vote this year On
February 26 Iran Ian's will elect an
entirely new assembly of experts for an
eight-year term even Ally hominid the
current supreme leader has acknowledged
that he's likely to die in that
Ronni and politics are really split
right now with moderates rapidly rising
after the nuclear deal helped to open up
the economy if they do well in
February's election then when homini
dies they might pick a new supreme
leader who shares their views that could
change Iran as we know it for a
generation this all goes to show that we
think of Iran as just another
dictatorship and indeed it does have a
dictator at the top but it's also a
democracy it's got loud political
disagreements vigorous debates over its
future this election February is a rare
moment once in a generation
when arounds Democratic elements become
more powerful than its theocratic
elements Ron Ian's have an opening here
to try to transform their country if
they take it and if they're successful
Iran could look very different for quite
a while